young Michael Jordan loves sports but
believe it or not he actually failed to
make his high school basketball team as
a freshman and a sophomore clifton pop
herring is the man who cut Michael
Jordan by the way and there's a lesson
in that for you value Tanner's 1 never
give up just because something's not
going well right now doesn't mean you
will not one day be great at it and
number 2 you will never make as big a
buffoon decision in your life as pop
herring did when he went on to cut the
greatest basketball player of all time
regardless of that buffoonery and
undeterred jordan continued to practice
and made the team the following year
after high school he accepted a
basketball scholarship to the University
of North Carolina where he played under
legendary head coach Dean Smith in
Jordan's first season in North Carolina
he was named the ACC Rookie of the Year
the Tar Heels won the ACC championship
and Jordan made the clutch jump shot
that beat Georgetown University for the
NCAA championship from my fellow Knick
fans out there this would kick off the
first of 20 straight years of Ewing
losing to Jordan in the clutch dagger
Jordan would go on leave the ACC in
scoring as a sophomore and as a junior
the Sporting News named him the college
Player of the Year both times and just
five years after being cut from high
school Michael Jordan was selected as
the third pick of the 1984 Draft by the
Chicago Bulls the Chicago Bulls pick
Michael Jordan
of North Carolina sorry pop you did cut
Jordan but there were two other teams
that drafted somebody not named Michael
Jordan what is happening here what type
of decision-making was going on in the
early 80s stop it
get some help prior to actually join the
Bulls Jordan was a member of the summer
84 the United States Olympic basketball
team that won the gold medal in Los
Angeles California the first of three
gold medals from Michael Jordan when
Jordan was drafted by the Chicago Bulls
they were actually a losing team drawing
only around 6000 fans two home games
Jordan quickly turned that around both
with his flamboyant style of play and
fierce spirit of competition Jordans
incredible leaping ability and hang time
thrilled fans and arenas around the
league in his first season he was named
to the all-star team and was later
honored as the league's Rookie of the
Year a broken foot would sideline Jordan
for 64 games in his sophomore season but
he returned to scored 49 points against
the Boston Celtics in the first game of
the playoffs and 63 in the second game
an NBA playoff record at the time the 86
87 season was again one of individual
successes and Jordan started in the
all-star game after receiving a record
million-and-a-half votes he became the
first player since Wilt Chamberlain to
score 3,000 points in a single season
and Jordan did it without being half a
foot taller than everybody else in the
league in 88 Jordan concentrated on
becoming a more complete player this
added attention to defense culminated
with him being named Defensive Player of
the Year he was also named the league's
MVP becoming the first player in league
history to lead the league in both
scoring and steals he was again named
MVP in that year's all-star game by
adding players like Scottie Pippen Bill
Cartwright Horace Grant John Paxson
around Jordan the Bulls management
created a strong team that won the 1991
NBA title defeating the Los Angeles
Lakers the very next year the Bulls
repeated his NBA champions beating Clyde
Drexler Portland Trail Blazers in 92
Jordan also played on the dream team
which participated in the summer Olympic
Games of Barcelona Spain the Olympic
Committee had voted to lift the ban on
professional athletes participating in
the games the team easily won the gold
medal winning their eight games by an
average margin of forty three point
seven points in 1993 after a tough
playoff series Woods again with Patrick
Ewing's New York Knicks the Bulls met
the Phoenix Suns for the NBA
championship
when it was over Jordan was again
playoff MVP in Chicago had won a third
straight title that summer Jordan's
father James was murdered by two men
during a robbery attempt Jordan had won
three straight NBA titles three regular
season MVP awards three playoff MVP
titles seven consecutive scoring titles
and he was a member of the all-star team
every year that he was in the league in
just nine seasons he had become the
Bulls all-time leading scorer amidst all
that controversy about his gambling
debts Michael Jordan retired from the
NBA in 94 95 to pursue a career
professional baseball Jordan played for
the Birmingham Barons of minor league
baseball team in the Chicago White Sox
system although the 17-month experiments
showed that he was not a major league
baseball player the experience and time
away from basketball provided the
much-needed rest and opportunity to
regain his love of basketball sidebar I
actually played some minor league
baseball believe it or not and Jordan
catches a lot of flack for how poorly he
played they threw him directly into
double-a and he batted over 200 if you
take any normal human being and put them
into double egg without playing baseball
since they were 15 years old they're
gonna faint
they're gonna crap themselves at the
plate I would bet every dollar that I
have against anything that 99.9 percent
of the people in the world could not
even make contact with a pitch thrown by
a double-a pitcher this guy after not
playing the game for 15 years batted 200
you should not give Jordan any flack if
anything that just goes to show what a
supreme unreal athlete the guy was